and talking about china a government
spokesman there has described a new
spike of kovit 19 cases in beijing as
explosive millions of residents face
mandatory testing after the outbreak was
traced back to a nightclub there schools
shops and restaurants in the district
have been closed an infected person was
at the club thursday and now authorities
link 166 new cases to that venue
beijing is back to mandatory testing and
targeted lockdowns
for residents of the city it's a major
blow many were hoping for a gradual
return to normalcy after restrictions on
indoor dining and other measures were
lifted just a week
ago but a covet 19 outbreak traced to
the popular heaven supermarket bar has
authorities scrambling to contain a
further spread of the virus
i am a little bit worried
lots of places and communities need to
be supervised now
because people went to that bar
so i am quite worried
about 10 000 close contacts of the bar's
patrons have been identified and their
residential buildings put under lockdown
the re-emergence of infections
highlights how hard it will be for china
to succeed in its zero covet policy
this approach has come with considerable
economic costs for china while other
countries shift to learning to live with
the virus
now for a closer look at this i'm not
joined by dw correspondent clifford uh
coonan who's lived in and reported from
china for uh many many years uh clifford
i
understand that you have actually been
to this heaven supermarket which is a
supermarket it's a bar or a mixture of
both what kind of place is it well it's
um it's a very trendy place in in san
diego district which is uh one of the
the the sort of the nightclub areas of
town um and it looks like a supermarket
and people get beer from from fridges
and then they go and pay for it and then
behind there's areas where lots of
people are sitting on couches
um falling asleep around midnight it's a
very packed area in fact if anywhere was
going to be a super spreader venue it
would be somewhere like the heavens
supermarket bar so busy very easy easy
to to catch that virus there
but people in china are not only worried
about the virus and this this new
outbreak
they are also worried about further
lockdowns more pressure on on
everyday lives what's the human and
economic cost of the china's very strict
zero covet policy well i think there's
this very clear economic cost maybe to
start with that you know in that it's
it's holding back the economy we saw
this lengthy lockdown in shanghai which
is knocked points off the economic
growth there um and we're going to
possibly see something of that like that
happening now in in the capital in
beijing which is what people were
worried about like and like we had in
the piece but also if you think about
the psychological impact this must be
having i mean
given that you know we're in this living
with the virus kind of mode in europe
and the west now this often feels a bit
like the start of the virus you know you
have a particular nightclub being a
super spreader and everything panicking
and things like that so it must be
having a terrible psychological toll on
people there how long have they keep
this up this this this zero corporate
policy well this is the thing i mean the
the who has said that it isn't
sustainable everyone is saying it's not
sustainable but um because it's got this
very important political dimension to it
the government has to you know stand by
it now having introduced it having said
that its policies are better than the
west policies it's very difficult to
start rolling it back certainly in a
very public kind of way so if it doesn't
work what's the political cost then for
the government well xi jinping has
really put a lot into this he's facing
into a big meeting about um where he's
going to really cement his leadership in
in november and this is going to be a
big factor in that i think he really
needs to show that this will be a
success i expect the communist party is
hoping that things just ease off i mean
we're still talking about a very small
number of cases and i i expect that
they're hoping that they will continue
to dwindle so that ultimately by this
important party congress in november
that he will be able to present present
the world with a win
our resident china watcher clifford
kuden thank you very much clifford